even many conservatives shy away from
naming the enemy Mr Spencer writes for
fear that it means war against a billion
Muslims but if Mr Spencer's arguments
are granted doesn't it it's a PC myth he
has written in the context of a
discussion not of Fringe terrorists but
of mainstream Islam and Islamic history
that we can negotiate with these people
quote and quote there's scarcely a
single ray of light in Mr Spencer's
relentlessly negative portrayal of Islam
and Islamic civilization
which seem Beyond Redemption and which
it appears must be utterly repudiated
accordingly for example Muslim Spain and
the Ottoman Empire widely recognized by
mainstream Scholars as relatively
tolerant places compared with then
contemporary Europe weren't tolerant at
all Islamic law lie steal and kill reads
one of his chapter headings he even
denigrates Muslim contributions to
science and philosophy it is thus
stunningly ironic to read Mr Spencer's
lament that quote Islamic theology so
devalues non-believers there's no in
Islamic culture for any generosity
toward their achievements end quote
there seems no place at all in Mr
Spencer's world for believing Muslims as
long as men read and believe the Quran
Mr Spencer writes in his Politically
Incorrect guide women will be despised
second class citizens subject to the
loss of virtually all of the most basic
human freedoms the war on terror he
declares in the opening sentence of his
book religion of peace is an ideological
conflict one in which Christians Jews
Buddhists Hindus atheists secular
Muslims and others have a stake notice
that while secular Muslims are included
as potential allies believing Muslims
are conspicuously omitted and now a few
points of many the Quran says Mr Spencer
exhorts Believers to fight unbelievers
the commands taken at face value are
open-ended and Universal however it's
just as possible to take them as
exhortations to fight specific hostile
unbelievers in Arabia in the early 7th
Century neither open-ended nor Universal
it's essential to know the context of
quranic verses what Muslims call the
asbab the reason for sending down or
occasions of Revelation Mr Spencer puts
aggressive military Jihad at the
absolute heart of Islam suggesting that
doing otherwise is untrue to the
classical texts but the 8th Century
jurist I jur regarded prayer and mosque
attendance as more important and did not
consider Jihad obligatory for all Al
bukari Muslim Andi report a saying of
Muhammad indicating helping widows in
the poor is Jihad another report has
Muhammad telling a man to go home and
care for his parents rather than going
out to fight the early sufan thi
believed that Jihad was primarily
defensive and that the only and that
only defensive Jihad was obligatory upon
individual Muslims so did The prominent
20th century reor of Alazar University
in Cairo Muhammad
shut Mr Spencer says that the quranic
phrase Jihad fil Allah striving in the
path of God means armed struggle to
establish the hegemony of the Islamic
social order this is to say the least of
it debatable the Arabic word Jihad means
simply striving the M ABD razak in the
Century for instance in addition to the
military defense of Islamic lands offers
striving daily to live righteously
through acts of worship as a specimen of
jihad along with earning a legal
livelihood and serving one's family
other early sources mentioned the
pursuit of knowledge spending money on a
good cause prayer giving alms and even
patience or patient endurance as
examples of non-military jihad curiously
the word harb or war is never conjoined
with the term Jihad in the Quran Mr
Spencer writes of Muhammad alleged
Ambitions of world domination however
modern Scholars like Montgomery Watt and
Carl Ernst reject them as later Retro
Retro from the Imperial period even if
the voices of moderation are rare muted
and too often in Exile which I grant
there's a genuine discussion going on
within Islam John Kel's arguing the just
war in Islam Carl erns following
Muhammad rethinking Islam in the
Contemporary world are two recent books
that Chronicle portions of that
discussion the essay is gathered in
Charles curtzman Source book entitled
liberal Islam and ASAS farin's admirable
new book the first Muslims history and
memory are illustrations of it Scholars
like gulam Ahmed abdulaziz sadina the
late F Rahman UCLA's KH Abul F figure in
it Ali Abdul razak argued that no
particular form of government is
required by Islam that a social order
compatible with Islam simply requires
Justice and Equity there's considerable
debate about the reliability of the
Hadith which had been used to justify
Jihadi violence the Contemporary Iranian
philosopher Abdul Karim R argues for the
legitimacy of religious pluralism and in
North Africa Muhammad talibi contends
islamically for religious liberty we
should be careful not to undercut such
people nor to award the Victor's Crown
to their opponents they have a difficult
enough challenge as it
is thank
you ladies and gentlemen we're fortunate
enough to have Robert Spencer himself to
respond to some of the accusations and
some of the statements Dr Peterson made
I also want to point out that Robert
Spencer will be available to the public
at a book signing after this uh 4:15
Booth
4:15 and without further Ado the
director of the Jihad watch which is a
news and commentary site that's updated
daily Robert Spencer
[Applause]
thank
you so many things to say in so little
time the question is uh uh whether to
speak about the elements of Islam that
are used by jihadists to justify
violence and supremacism and oppression
in various ways is to validate those
interpretations of Islam and to undercut
those Muslims who are trying to reform
those things this is a very important
question and I don't think that it can
be approached unless we have an accurate
understanding of the facts on the ground
Dr Peterson quite correctly stated at
the beginning of his talk that there is
no single Islam that there is in the
first place the Sunni and Shiite divide
and in the second place four schools of
Sunni jurist Prudence as well as other
schools of Juris Prudence uh he did not
mention however that there is a broad
consensus consensus is a very important
imma is a very important uh Concept in
Islamic
theology Muhammad prophesied that his
community would not agree on an error
and so what is reached as a point of
consensus by the various schools of
Islamic law is considered to be a
question that is settled and sure now
this is Islamic theology this is not my
opinion these are matters of record that
the schools of Islamic Juris Prudence do
agree and have a consent census on the
necessity to wage war against
unbelievers Dr Peterson mentioned the
four schools of Sunni Juris Prudence The
shafii Maliki hanafi and hanbali all of
them agree that Jihad is a precept of
divine institution that it is uh
preferable to First invite the
non-muslims to accept Islam and if they
refuse to fight them I am uh quoting in
part the words of iban abiz kirani who
is a Maliki jurist the jurist from one
of these schools of of Juris prudence
and kirwani was actually working from
the words of Muhammad himself as
recorded in the Hadith collection sahim
Muslim when he said to meet the
unbelievers invite them to accept Islam
if they refuse invite them to enter the
Islamic social order as as the dees the
second class citizens as mandated by
Islamic law and an
institutionalized uh status of
discrimination the they would not enjoy
equality of rights under the law with
the Muslims and if they refused both to
go to war with them conversion
subjugation or War being set out by
Muhammad in what are considered to be
canonical Hadith Hadith that are
authentic by all the schools of Islamic
law and all the Orthodox sects of Islam
now the a lot of the confusion comes
from the difficulty of dealing with
these facts this is not to say that
there that no modern reformers exist it
is to say that it is an element of
traditional and mainstream Islam and a
point of agreement among the various
differing sects of Islam that Warfare
against unbelievers and their
subjugation under the rule of Islamic
law is part of the responsibility of the
Muslim Community now he says that if
this is true Dr Peterson says that this
would be very disheartening
unfortunately there are some truths that
are disheartening and what we have to do
is realistically work from that point to
try to come up with some kind of a
solution that is actually workable
rather than Retreat into fantasies half
truths and deceptions that are much more
comforting much more heartening but
unfortunately false